faire entrer le chlordécone dont le
tableau des maladies professionnelles
c'était l'une des promesses du président
de la république lors de son passage en
septembre 2018
hier à l'assemblée nationale la
commission denquête a interrogé les
professionnels chargés de la mise en
place de cette mesure
la caisse centrale de mutualité agricole
et son travail ne fait que commencer
on en est injuste a été la doit à parler
de ses tableaux nous ne savons pas
encore s'il y aura un tableau s'il n'y
en aura pas et on en est plutôt aux
études épidémiologiques et aux arguments
qui sont pour
quels sont les arguments positifs pour
faire une relation certaine entre cancer
de la prostate et corps des tonnes
actuellement il existe plusieurs
maladies professionnelles liées aux
pesticides mais aucune n'a été déclarée
en martinique pour permettre une
indemnisation des dégâts du chlordécone
il faudra d'abord accepté d'y relier une
maladie comme le cancer de la prostate à
ce sujet au vu des dernières
publications de l'inserm le langage
officiel semble évoluer mais la
pollution au chlordécone reste un cas
très particulier la notion de riveraine
stricto sensu au sens professionnel me
semble-t-il un va être très difficile à
définir
il faudra aller au delà et définir
quelque chose qui relèverait de la de la
santé publique auquel cas c'est à vous
le législateur certainement de définir
la méthode qui arrivent et qui seraient
des conséquences ultérieures est tardive
d'une application qui certes a été
limité au départ mais qui au fil des
décennies a pu effectivement se
disséminer au final l'indemnisation ne
relèvera que d'une volonté politique
c'est également la conclusion des
experts auditionnés hier qui ont
souligné le rôle des élus dans les
décisions futures